mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
simplify the following sum of three
fractions
the first fraction is equal to one
divided by one plus log base a of the
product bc
the second fraction is one divided by
one plus log base b of the product ac
and the third fraction is one divided by
one plus log base c of the product a b
a b and c are greater than zero but none
of them is equal to one
i thank rookvade for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall the change of base formula
log base b of u is equal to log base a
of u divided by log base a of b
this is for numbers that are greater
than zero and the bases a and b are not
equal to 1.
suppose a is equal to the constant e
the logarithm then becomes the natural
logarithm and that's the form of the
formula i'll use in the video
recall the product rule of logarithms
log base b of the product x y
is equal to log base b of x plus log
base b of y
all of the numbers are greater than zero
and the base b is not equal to one
let's now tackle the original problem
we'll use the change of base formula on
each of the logarithms
the first logarithm transforms into the
natural log of the product bc divided by
the natural log of a
the second will transform into the
natural log of the product ac divided by
the natural log of b the third logarithm
will become the natural log of the
product a b
divided by the natural log of c
we will now simplify each of these
fractions
for the first term we'll multiply it by
the natural log of a divided by the
natural log of a
the numerator becomes the natural log of
a and the denominator becomes the
natural log of a plus the natural log of
the product bc
we'll do a similar thing for the second
fraction
we'll multiply it by the natural log of
b divided by the natural log of b
the numerator becomes the natural log of
b and the denominator becomes the
natural log of b plus the natural log of
the product ac
the third term will multiply by the
natural log of c divided by the natural
log of c
the numerator becomes the natural log of
c and the denominator becomes the
natural log of c plus the natural log of
the product a b
we will now look at this denominator
and we'll use the product rule
we have a sum which we will convert into
the product
the natural log of a plus the natural
log of the product bc
will be equal to the natural log of abc
we do the same thing in the second
fraction the natural log of b plus the
natural log of the product ac will be
equal to the natural log of the product
abc
in the third fraction we have the
natural log of c plus the natural log of
the product a b
and this will become the natural log of
the product abc
now each of these three fractions have
the same denominator the natural log of
the product abc
thus we can sum them and sum the
numerators
it becomes the natural log of a plus the
natural log of b plus the natural log of
c all over the natural log of the
product abc
we then use the product rule one more
time
the natural log of a plus the natural
log of b plus the natural log of c is
equal to the natural log of the product
abc
and this simplifies because we have the
natural log of the product abc over the
natural log of the product abc and
that's equal to one and that's our
answer
what a neat problem involving logarithms
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you soon on mind your decisions
where we solve the world's problems one
video at a time
[Music]
you